It all started slowly, then the
magic began. Two years ago, we were attacked by the king of the demons of this world.Won't you
lend us your strength? Hey,
heroes, I
just got caught up in this, and you
won't tell me if you don't tell me.  I'll be with you
on the front lines of the battlefield to
treat the injured.In other words, he's a vanguard.He's got great
muscles.I've decided to help him when I'm in a pinch.He's an
upstanding man who fights to protect Ruto and his seniors.He's a member
of the lifesaving team.  Is it
possible for me to run to save an injured person? If I
die, I'll fix it and be friends. It's
okay, you idiot. It's just a daily routine. I
understand why you train your body so much. In this way, you can
also protect your life.  I'm the lifeguard. I won't fight. I won't
kill the enemy, but I
'll help everyone who only I can help. I'm the lifeguard.
[Applause] I'm a
blood magician from another world. Now, what
will happen?
DET